I don't necessarily have like a list of
screenplays like read these screenplays
and then you're gonna be an awesome
screenwriter it's more give yourself
exposure to a lot of different styles of
writing a lot of different genres
I love Aaron Sorkin obviously right so
the social network that's one that's a
screenplay that I've read over and over
again I really love Alex Garland's ex
machina that's one of my favorite films
it's a really well-done screenplay again
it's you know a theme and a genre that
I'm interested in
lately I have actually I've been
revisiting the truman show that that
screenplay
because when when that came out it was
it was very you know novel it was a very
interesting idea and it actually shaped
me in a lot of ways because you know you
have those moments where you're like am
I on the training show like how powerful
of a screenplay to be able to do that
and to create like a psychosis everybody
says you have to write and read every
day because it's true if you're if
you're writing every day you know the
next day you're gonna you're gonna write
a little better than you did the day
before and in four years you're gonna be
a much better writer than you were four
years ago and I think a lot of writers
you're waiting to for the world to give
you permission to pursue your craft and
you just need it you need to give
yourself that permission you need to
show up and say okay I'm gonna do this
and I might not be very good right now
or you know maybe I am great and I don't
know it yet you won't know either way
unless you put yourself out there and
sitting down every day whether that's
you know for an hour in the morning an
hour in the evening somewhere in between
the timing doesn't matter and it really
doesn't even matter you know if you're
writing a thousand words or if you're
writing fifty the important thing is
that you're writing powerful stories ask
questions so they they work in such a
way that the audience is constantly
wondering why did that happen or where
is this taking us and and as soon as you
and you have tit you can't ask a
question and then answer it at the end
you have to ask a little question you
have to answer it
in the next scene or the next chapter or
whatever it is but then you have to pose
another question and so really a
powerful story is one that continues to
ask questions and deliver meaningful
answers and that satisfactory answers I
don't remember who said that but it's
something that I've definitely followed
in my work and it's a way that I a tool
that I use to keep the audience engaged
you're in the middle of your of your
script in the middle of your story and
you're just stuck that happens a lot
a lot more than I care to a bit a lot of
times really you just need to give
yourself space so whether that space
from that's particular scene or space
from the project as a whole like you
know yourself best and you have to you
have to listen to yourself a lot of
times you know I'll be in the middle of
you know of a scene or a piece of
dialogue even and I'm just like I can't
like I just need a break and I'll go for
a walk and I think a lot of writers use
walking as a tool to kind of help the
juices start flowing again just get
outside get into a different environment
into a different mentality and then try
and revisit the work later yeah we
always have our phones with us so walk
away from the script give yourself space
and you know when the answer comes it
comes and you'll be ready to harness it
that's that's the advice that I have to
keep telling myself you know it's okay
to walk away but but it's not okay to
give up rewrite and rewrite and rewrite
there's so many different drafts but
like just the act of writing it kind of
gets things moving and you create that
momentum and you get to a place where
you can you're putting you're fitting
the pieces together you know and it any
screen player any story it really is a
puzzle and it's a matter of arranging
those pieces in a way that makes sense
and that's meaningful and that's when
writing becomes really fun you have to
find a middle ground between you know
your creative intention
and what's gonna sell getting to a
script that will sell a lot of times you
know like for me personally I'm really
interested in the characters and kind of
their internal worlds but the producer
might want something that you know want
a thriller it needs to be edgy it needs
to be sexy and you you need to find a
middle ground as a screenwriter because
yeah you can write a beautiful
screenplay but are you gonna be happy if
it doesn't sell and so you have to
answer that question for yourself and so
it's it's give and take there are
certain things that I really push back
on in terms of character and motivation
you know I think there's our ways that
you can amp up the edginess amp up the
sex without like totally killing your
children you know killing your darlings
so I think that that means something
different to everybody and you have to
find what your hard line is and that
differs project a project and producer
to producer the sooner you start like
the more material you'll have the the
quicker you'll learn the better you'll
become I mean I I kick myself for not
for not really giving it my all you know
when I was in high school in college in
my early 20s
um you know I think we always like look
back and say all these were missed
moments or missed opportunities and you
can't do too much of that but really you
need a look at like okay like what's
your goal or what's what is that dream
scenario that that vision that you have
for yourself and you need to really you
really need to face every decision off
of that like does this get me closer to
that goal and if the answer is no why
are you doing it like what are you how
are you gaining or you know how are you
benefiting as a person a lot of times
it's just like you know what experiences
can I have that are going to later
inform my writing and that's a fun way
to live you know so and it's it it
really allows you to take risks
and say you know what if this turns out
to be like a terrible mistake
and failure it will at least still be a
good story that's oversimplifying things
of course but it's really it's helped me
overcome a lot of those fears it's
important to have a supportive community
around you for those times when you know
you're feeling down or you're feeling
you know you're questioning your work
and questioning how good of a writer you
are or you know the path or whatever
it's important to have people who are
there to cheer you on even if they don't
understand the craft or understand what
you're trying to accomplish just just to
be a cheerleader I think that's
important because then it makes you know
the solitary work of being a writer less
solitary less isolating becoming a
successful writer just meant that I
could focus and dedicate my life to
writing I mean really that was that was
that exciting aha moment for me of
course you know seeing seeing when I
when I physically held my book I cried I
think you know hopefully God willing
like when the screenplay is is produced
and has its premiere I mean that moment
is going to be so surreal and I won't
lie to you I've definitely envisioned it
many times and I think that you have to
you have to visualize it and know okay
that's where I'm aiming so but you know
that that would be success but I think
success really is a moving target and
it's always going to take on a new
definition and a new a new feeling for
me but just dedicating my life to
writing that I think that's the ultimate
success and then wherever I go from here
I mean that's who knows